russia's aggression against ukraine is
particularly alarming for people in the
u.s who have friends or family in that
country our national correspondent
jerica duncan spoke with an exchange
student whose parents live in eastern
ukraine not far from the border with
russia jericho good morning good morning
obviously a lot of fear and concern as
we've heard throughout the morning
19-year-old anja hapachonke is a college
freshman studying in dallas we first
interviewed her tuesday afternoon she
told us she's been in touch with her
parents every day and trying not to
panic well shortly after last night's
escalation we spoke with her again to
see if she'd been able to reach them
it was 5 am in the morning
like moscow time and ukrainian time as
well anja hapoichiko says as soon as she
heard russian president vladimir putin
announced what he called a military
operation in ukraine she called her
parents to warn them so basically i woke
them up with
a phone call um like messenger call um
and i told them that well you know
what's happening because i i saw this
information
and um
they were like well we don't know we
were just we were just sleeping and
that's it hapoichiko says her parents
home is roughly 60 miles from the
russian border they told her they had
not heard any gunfire yet and are now
planning to leave today
i realized that my parents are you know
making some progress in actually packing
stuff
and things to leave my hometown
quite soon the official website of
ukraine's parliament she says has been
taken down probably because so people
won't receive any updates or any other
information i would think so
hapoinchiko told us that living with
this threat has been a part of daily
life but this is the first time her
parents have ever decided to leave
hapoinchiko's brother her niece and
boyfriend are also in ukraine everyone
she says at this point is really just
seeking safety and we did speak to some
other ukrainian americans that have been
here now for at least 15 or 20 years and
the sentiment was fear
it was i've always known that there's
been a threat but now it feels real and
i even reached out to the woman that we
spoke to who wasn't in our piece
um but she said she has not been able to
reach her family yet and her biggest
concern is not having the communication
and wondering if that breaks down then
what and there's no plan yeah absolutely
terrifying you know we've been talking
about how this affects the us right you
know throughout all of this coverage and
one of it is that we're a country of
immigrants and there are huge ukrainian
communities here in in in america like
in chicago where i live and all the
people that you spoke to right and when
we we went to lehigh valley which is
right outside of philadelphia um they
have a substantial ukrainian population
there too but
um
there's so much as you guys have been
talking about all morning long there's
so much history there's so much to
understand about before uh the soviet
union and and when it broke up but um
honestly i think it's just
prayer is what we heard a lot of i'm
just praying for my family in ukraine
and that's all we can do i can send
money i can send food i can send
clothing but i can't
make sure that my family is going to be
safe and this is all counter uh putin's
idea that they're all part of a russian
history a common history three quarters
of the people in ukraine speak ukrainian
not russian they're ukrainian not
russian yeah and adriana you make a good
point as we sit here thinking about
inflation and the conflict and impact it
has on us right you think about the
ukrainian people that are spread out
throughout the world that are worried
about friends and family absolutely in
this moment we have to keep them in our
thoughts and prayers that's enrique
thank you so much